[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett joining us today once again as
part of our ear biscuits at VidCon
series is OG youtuber and the Guinness
world record holder for most consecutive
daily vlogs posted on YouTube Charles
Trippy now Charles is truly a pioneer of
Internet tainment and a friend of ours
he launched his Charles Trippy channel
way back in May of 2006 and immediately
began defining a genre of clickable web
content in 2008 he started a second
channel the CTFxC AKA internet killed
television and uploaded daily vlogs over
there and he hasn't stopped for going on
seven years that's right Charles has
been uploading a vlog basically a
reality montage of highlights of his day
every day for seven years and he hasn't
missed a single day hence the record and
it turns out a lot happens over that
amount of time for one you amassed 1.5
million subscribers and over 670 million
video views you also share life-altering
experiences like a surprise engagement
proposal vacations getting tattoos
touring with his band we the kings
divorce and even brain surgery the dude
has filmed his own brain surgery and he
kept going right through it sharing his
daily life on YouTube to this day making
him arguably the most determined vlogger
of all time and we talked to him about
that determination his process and the
motivation by this choice to bear all of
his life to his fans we also spoke about
those brain tumors the brain tumors that
he had and the surgeries that he had to
go through his result he tells the whole
story of how it went down and also how
flogging became a therapeutic way for
him to deal with it he also describes
the whole process around how he was able
to vlog his entire brain surgery the
second brain surgery and you're gonna
want to stick around to hear about that
and later in the conversation we talked
about something that we've been anxious
to talk with Charles about for some time
and that is his relationship with three
different Ally's including what it was
like to experience the massive fan
reaction to a separation
from his wife Allie speed and his
perspective on all of the internet
speculation behind that in we know it
wasn't easy for Charles to talk about
all this stuff with us I mean he already
put it out there over the course of the
years of experience but in fact he said
it's the first time that he went back
and kind of encapsulated it in a
conversation and talked about and
started to process some of that divorce
again so we really do appreciate Charles
being open with us and our friendship
with him we had a great conversation and
we know you'll enjoy it too but first we
want to take a moment to remind you to
support internet Ament by getting some
of our merch y'all
rhettandlink.com/store if you want to
find more ways to express your mythical
beast hood head over there to
rhettandlink.com/store check out all the
things we got available like bobbleheads
hoodies posters wristbands shirts hats
coffee mugs all of that can be found
over there rental income slash store
again it's a great way to express your
mythical beast and also support internet
Ament thanks for doing that now on to
the biscuit I was telling I was trying
to remember the exact timeline of like
us first meeting and then very good I
don't remember it just kind of happened
well I know the first time we met in
person was in Philly
in 2008 Oh was it one of those yotube
things yeah you were going to that right
now we were just there for we were doing
videos without cheese take this and you
came with yeah that's right yeah that
was the Geno's and Pat's thing right
yeah so that's the first time we met in
person but we certain we certainly knew
you of you before then and I think we
may have been like Internet yeah we ran
yeah yes you had a haircut by that point
no one Google that no one no one Google
that I look like didn't have hair with
like it was purple at times and that was
gone by the time we met oh that was gone
yeah I'm almost glad that I'm less than
less embarrassed I do remember though at
the Gino's a past thing it was when I
was a vegetarian yeah I remember telling
you guys that and I remember getting
spat on by I think it was the Geno's guy
those
the ones that had like the it looks like
Guy Fieri oh yeah flash all the flash
the flashing he was upset he was very
upset with me that I was vegetarian
who's like why are you here yeah I was
just like bread and cheese please
remember that that's cheese bread and
melts melts was there no it was the one
that brought all I yeah I remember that
it was a lot of fun yeah and at
bassmaster was there and a couple other
people too I put old long time ago oh
yeah you are your Internet old dude
you're you're older than as we are here
no your Internet older than us a little
bit in a no in terms of being
established I mean yeah absolutely I
you're a pioneer that's what I'm I don't
know guys back in the day though like
when I started I was watching you guys
oh really yeah
like all your songs and stuff I remember
that we had a backlog of songs but yeah
because I remembered like really
admiring the fact that you guys
harmonizing together it was like you see
both you guys did you get the dynamic
and it guys nailed it every single time
I was just really impressed all the time
you know this is mine blows mind blowing
well but we were I remember thinking you
were getting traction you know it's like
because we there was a time early on
where we were like trying to figure out
like who's who's doing this right right
no one responds we're doing it right
when I look back on your channel the
Charles Trippy channel which was like I
guess you would call it your sketch
chance sketches but as my channel yeah
yeah and I mean I'm just struck with how
you were like I said pioneering but you
were inventing a genre of sensationally
titled shareable concept like trapped in
a claw machine and there is you're in a
claw machine yeah were you actually in
the comics I was I used to work at a
movie theater and my job was to restock
the claw machine and to read ticket
here's a fun little sack did you guys
know those things are rigged they're
supposed to like soon but the claw is
supposed to clamp
X amount of times like harder so that
way not every single time you win
something yeah so I was supposed to do
it like every like 20 times or something
like that you know so 1 in 20 chance to
actually get something and I thought
that was really kind of up so I would
choose and I would make it like one in
one
five or something like that or one in
one and I remembered one time there's
like a setting on the back it was like a
setting that you had to kind of go into
like a flathead screwdriver I was like a
computer setting and stuff like that it
was so messed up I thought it was so
screwed up so every time I would do it I
like take it down every single time and
the reason why I was in there is because
I had to refill it again because right
boss
found out because he was like wondering
why the thing would go from here to here
machine keep four days yeah Robin Hood
kind of yeah for cheap toys that we
thought that would be a funny idea you
know I always wanted to do that because
you see babies on the news getting stuck
in a train right so like why not I got
the key let's just do it and your job to
be channel on the job I was editing and
filming on the job so I was get fired no
they actually supported it I worked at
an IMAX theatre and I worked at another
movie theater like Amy theater and
that's where actually without that kind
of stuff I would not have been able to
do it clubs in college you have no time
when you're in college right I would go
to work go upstairs in the production
booth and whatever cut the movies press
play do nothing I would drink with my
boss upstairs we would get Bailey's and
coffee is so cool right Bailey's the
coffee we're the awesome people right
yeah woods drink get drunk move the
movies dollies with the boss Yeah right
switch to the real switch the real witch
is a pain in the ass to this day I hate
King Kong because I dropped it yeah
because it's probably as big as this
table you guys can see this table put
like twice the width of this table you
know is this math well I don't do any of
that anymore I quit in the wrong time
another video I can make you yawn oh
yeah I remember that one which we I mean
Rena found ourselves doing I can make
you yawn video three years ago yeah yeah
and then we we like search we're like
I'm sure somebody's done this and then
of course you pop up from like seven
years earlier it was like six years ago
okay I can make you yawn and then like
best sleeping pranks and it's got you
know the thumbnail is you would like a
copy on your face and pop rocks and coke
myth it's just like you know it was like
premonition type stuff that you were
seeing the future of what was going to
work on YouTube which is funny cuz I had
no idea what
doing that was but it but it but you had
honed it to a craft even back then like
the sensational titles and people did
you know you had to click yeah you gotta
do like I remember as a kid my grandma
breeds to read those national Enquirer's
and that's the only reason why did you
open those things so I thought maybe
kind of doing the same thing for YouTube
with it yeah the same thing cuz I mean
if you guys back in the day would watch
anything on YouTube you'd be you
wouldn't watch like day 400 or untitled
vlog you know you wouldn't do that no
one would ever do that that's why I kind
of got annoyed with anyone with titling
videos they're like yeah oh it's totally
fake you know I mean it's like or
misleading comments or misleading titles
right it's like that didn't happen it's
like would you read honestly watch a
video called untitled vlog mm like no
one ever watch a movie like that right
is it fair to say that you've tried
everything like I mean can I name
anything like boobs of course you've
done boobs I've done boobs male and
female anything I mean you've got in in
terms of the technology whenever you to
become out with something like well one
of the most viewed videos on that
channel still is longest video ever on
YouTube yeah I reminisce some how it was
before they put in they probably put in
the restriction that was because of you
it was a not it was almost a ten-hour
video yeah there was the first
restriction back in the day there was no
time restriction was only a file size on
file size it was 100 Meg's and I
remember that file being it's why it
looks like crap if you try to find it it
was ten hours or something like that but
yeah when you stretch out and try to
export it back in the day you try to do
that on like I was doing iMovie out mm
seriously it just exploded so you would
have to like compress it and compress it
again and compress it smaller and come I
remember compressing probably 10 times
to get it under 100 Meg's to be able to
do that and then gone online now now
there's like no limit you know you can
put a movie up there
right brain for 25 years there was a
time limit to that they added later and
then you had to you had to be a certain
type of partner to have that removed but
if you have that removed can you just do
it indefinitely yeah if you look you can
look for like like I've used sound
effects like you can look like rain like
rain found sound like on YouTube look at
the rain
Thunder yeah and it's like 25 hours or
something like that so I don't think
there's a limit anymore yeah it's
probably not but you would be the one to
formulate these questions and then
scientifically by guessing and checking
or compressing in this case find out the
answer of course the next video you
released was the shortest video ever on
YouTube I thought that was kind of a
goal I had to do that somebody was so
pissed about it so it's like you know
what was the motivation for like what
were you doing at a time that was like
I'm gonna do this YouTube thing I'm
gonna wait so I'm gonna be aggressively
okay I'm gonna be thin YouTube to my so
I started you know myspace back in the
day you guys don't know what myspace it
still might be available you know I was
doing that and I had a bet with my
roommate at the time to get more friends
I won and then skip doing that kind of
stuff and then I was making videos with
other friends at the movie theater and
we would put on our website and
bandwidth sucked then you don't I mean
oh yeah you'd have to put a QuickTime
video up there you'd have to spend like
$80 a month for like five use of your
video yeah if you were paying for the
hosting yeah so it's one person watch a
video like 100 megabyte videos like 500
megabytes right there you actually
didn't want people to watch your video
you're like don't watch it seriously and
then my friend Ricky lived out here and
he showed me YouTube and at the time it
was only available to just I mean it was
only you really used for uploading a
video embedding it somewhere there was
no community or anything like that so I
was doing that and then one day it was
just on the site and I noticed that
there was things called there was like
channels and subscription boxes and
things like that and I was like alright
something's gonna happen here so then I
was like had so much time in the theatre
you know I was just like alright so just
keep making more videos networking
around I did the just kind of looked
around like lisanova like those are
renetto back in the day just kind of saw
what they were doing
yeah and just kind of even Nulty was
back in the day - mhm and there's -
seeing what they were kind of doing and
then almost mimicking it and just to
kind of see that there was actually a
channel forming and once I saw that I
just dropped my space altogether and
some obvious right now yeah then it was
pre no it was a decisions like which
baby do you keep right
were very fixated on MySpace oh yeah oh
yeah like the livejournal pack in the
day mm-hmm and you know Friendster and
all those things huh but um no I then it
just it just I was like oh I'm making
videos I'm just gonna keep doing this
and you were watching other people but I
mean there were sketches out there like
the lisanova Lisa Novus of the world and
there were blogging like the brunette oh
right or like the lifestyle vlog that
like nulls would do yeah so net own
notes were way ahead other time I think
brunette Oh especially like nobody got
what he was doing like he thought he was
this crazy guy then they realized he was
wait I love not uh brunette oh but I
mean he was he is a crazy guy but right
he would take a vlog but he would make
this like crazy sensational thing like
you were saying and he would like you
know the head would explode or something
like that
uh-huh I remember that one or his Mentos
or something like that and then it would
just make this a really entertaining
vlog but it was actually kind of like a
skit so you kind of see what that's
going on and you kind of like you know
build off and we were you just thinking
like I mean nobody was really thinking
of a career back then no because we'd
know what he knew what was gonna lead to
but what were you thinking like did you
have another thing that you wanted to do
like as a career where you let
absolutely a rock star know why everyone
has that kind of thing I grew up on it
with my dad and stuff like that so right
I wanted that at one point and I did
that for a while
well then I'd quit go to college so I
was in college didn't know what I wanted
to do pick a book degree got that degree
that uh this kind of lived up in Tampa
where USF was where I kind of like
graduated from at what point did you
make up the last name trippy that's your
real last name okay real last name right
and I'm the third so so yeah it's
actually it's it's not a funny stories
it's kind of a sad story because when
Mike grant grandfather came over here
grandparents Ellis Island they didn't
want it and I for those two
I guess Italian so they made it a why to
be more American so it's a PRI pbi yeah
so if you see him beat repeat a very few
with a Y but so like you there's like a
what's his name
Charles Trippy
a little football player back in the day
have had it with an eye okay yeah so
you'll see with an eye but very few with
a why think is all my family probably
they're the only ones who made that
decision
yeah he's go with the why we got screwed
they did it to him yeah the guide Ellis
Island yeah it was just kind of like g2a
why yeah though I'm sorry yeah got it
yeah so when they got there they're like
okay that's two Italian you're why get
out there welcome Annika yeah kind of
things like Americanized it right yeah
it really works is a YouTube channel
does it does because you have people you
would have all these people like with
the user names like renetto lisanova you
know stuff like that you know LT Kevin
dolts or something like that right and
you don't realize I would sit there and
think of one I'm just like oh man it
works you had vision yeah I was lazy
okay so at the time you're doing this
early on you're working at a theater
which you know is not typically the
thing that leads to a lifelong career
right and you probably didn't think so
so is it just like a game to you was it
I'm just gonna see if I can master this
it was kind of a game cuz there was also
google video remember that before Google
bought YouTube yeah that's kind of
submitted and bought YouTube so it was
kind of a game we would upload a video
to YouTube we would upload a video to
Google Video
oh no there's another website at the
time and we would see which video got
more that's crazy
and we do we kind of like lay bets and
like with people we made the videos
we're like oh my god I remember there
was a video out there they got a hundred
views and we free herself really a
hundred views back at the back in 2005 I
mean that was 100 views I mean you could
pay up like hunter time stay on a
website that's insane yeah but um and
then there was a comment and you'd be
like holy God somebody saw this and was
compelled to say something yeah they
give it five stars what's going on here
and it I mean it you tapped into the
social nature of a two so I mean you got
your friend so you're like placing bets
about things but then very quickly you
became known and you knew other people
at least that's my impression of it
right yes I thought
was like the the idea of YouTube is kind
of connecting and making friends you
know I mean through that I'm like I am a
very awkward person I mean you guys know
I've met you in person a million times
I'm very awkward and socially that's
socially awkward like I'm pretty good at
it but they'd be this as our job like I
don't like going out and going to
parties and stuff like that I'd rather
just sit home watch a movie versus
because this is what we do for a living
we go out and we make these videos so
we're very entertaining so it was just
kind of like one of those things where I
just kind of liked doing it and it was
this is weird I mean YouTube in general
is just weird when you think about the
whole should write a book right everyone
else says yeah but you don't have time
no let's make a vlog well in in yeah
let's talk about that B transcribe
everything that was another it's become
probably the most significant innovation
that you know the daily sells is the
daily vlog so okay was anyone else doing
that today okay so Shay Shay started
doing that just technically adults I
mean yeah you know I was doing it just
wasn't before that has consistent yeah
yeah different kind of thing was like
two minutes of something pranking his
family or something like that
so it wasn't every single day he does
did it every day he did yeah cuz I
remember it was Shay and I were talking
about it we thought it might've been the
kiss of death if we made a video every
single day because we noticed when he
went every single day his views dropped
mm-hmm so he thought we thought it might
have been the kiss of death
I remember Shay and I talking about that
for a very long time yeah it's not
sounding like a slogan that was like
every time you take a crap on a video
yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah he was way
ahead of his time I mean it sucks at a
lot of people don't know he is yeah I
wish a lot of people did because he was
his pioneering he was one of the first
but then you and Shay decided in
parallel right now she's the solution it
was Shay first and then after the first
month he thought he called me he was
like you better do this and I was like
well I don't know my knife is not that
interesting and he just do it and I'm
like I don't have like seven kids to do
it yeah it's like you know I'm in
college I don't time so and then I just
it was like alright I'm gonna do it and
I started doing it and if i watch the
old ones i cringe because you have the
old flip where it's like you're jerking
around jello and stuff like that
technology wasn't there
yeah and doing it like everyday that
kind of wasn't like the goal it just so
happened cuz I feel like I'm the type I
have a very stubborn person when it
comes to doing something and like if I
put my mind to something I'm not gonna
stop so it's just the principle of
saying that you started you can't stop
yeah you can't stop and I'd ever thought
like I didn't realize I never stopped
until somebody pointed out like a couple
years later they're like you realize
you'd never stopped in two years I'm
like oh and then at that point I was
like okay well let's keep going let's
make something of this and then after
three or four years you know somebody
plain common tech with Guinness World
Records and then I was like all right
why would I make this contact last so I
kept doing it and then I hear five or
six they gave us that right so I didn't
rely there was no plan on doing it every
single day it was this like I mean I
said daily vlogs but I thought it's
gonna do with daily vlogs
you know it's whenever I got a chance
right and now we're what what's the
unbroken streak now 2276 seven years and
the Guinness record do you actually get
like a plaque yeah I put LexA helm there
literally on my office I've two of them
now they give you one every year oh
really um well they give you one every
year because they update the book but
right and you took out the record yeah
and they didn't give me one last year
because this kept the same record but
this year they saw the significant jump
for the one from 1500 to 2000 707
there's a bigger jump we should update
it so yeah they literally give you this
plaque it's like an award on as cool as
the play buttons for YouTube but it's
like a plaque it says Guinness World
Record you know little certificates and
stuff like that right and you had to
develop I mean that developed over time
you know there's an art form to doing
the daily vlog it's like a formula so
give us the formula it's you wake up you
introduce yourself you like you wake up
you're kind of like you guys deal with
the with this you say hello
yeah introduce what's going on you don't
really say what you're gonna talk about
you just do it and whatever happens in
the day that happens in the day and then
you edit it to the end of the night and
then we you see a community because you
guys have a huge community behind this
and then you see that and then you
evolve them and then
when you pick something so at the end of
the day you're uploading your how many
day in an ideal schedule I know
sometimes it probably fluctuates yeah it
has it depends on what you can't really
get ahead no you can't well it depends
on what you're doing like if you're kind
of I said what do you mean like you
can't be in the next day that what you
mean yeah like there's no buffer because
no yeah yeah you sleep and then you wake
up and do it again
yeah you got to do it again so exactly
so you have to you get home that night
at the end of the day you're like
editing and uploading something that
goes out the next day like next morning
yeah so how streamlined has it gotten at
this point in terms of I can do it in my
sleep
so because I assume now that there's
like you are your self editing as you're
shooting you're like I know this is I
know beginning of this look this is the
end of the clip yeah I'm not trimming
anymore yeah so is it like a you open it
up and you just did it back-to-back you
just throw him Elizabeth J and the L
unlike final yeah yeah and yeah exactly
you know you shoot the edit first he
used to shoot kind of thing and then
like che like che was always like him
and I would always talk about it cuz
like him and I to our videos back in the
day like 30 minutes long yeah which is
ridiculous like a TV show and then we
started like well I started finding
myself at least he still does it but I
was like I can't watch that much like so
I figured my down a little bit the more
exciting stuff like highlights yeah and
but it's the same thing like you said
it's like you shoot to edit kind of
thing so you know where it is and then
I've been teaching Ally how to do it too
so she's understanding that - so when
she had it's some of the times she knows
how to do it but yeah that way you're
not like basically because you know when
yet it's real time sometimes longer so
if you shoot like 60 minutes it's gonna
you can't do it in 60 minutes longer
than that and then so it's still either
your ally editing at this point you're
there's nobody like that's gonna be like
okay you guys are sick today I'm gonna
come in and do this no no no yeah gotta
do it got to do it through everything
you know I've helped everyone's helped
me in the past my parents have helped my
sister's help you know ally ally speed
has helped back in the day and stuff
like that everyone's held me and there's
I mean there's certain points where it's
like oh like I gotta get to the Internet
in order to upload this dude's gonna be
like crazy mo my god that's orange and
touring
like the word can't imagine we've gone I
remember one day specifically it was a
day almost lost her record was in London
and it was pouring raining and we got
invited you guys know the ban thrice
nothing so I know I know the one before
it
Oaks Weiss advice tried trying to make a
new Murali
Nuala numerological joke a mistake well
if anyone listening those thrice they
had a going away tour and they invited
the band because we were overseas
touring okay and they invited us to go
watch and I was one of my bands I loved
as a kid
mm-hmm and I had to miss it because I
had to walk around London in the rain
trying to find internet and I literally
would go up to people's doors and hotels
asking like have their Wi-Fi password
really yeah and I got one finally said
yeah I got it as if you don't if it was
what's the rule if you don't if it
doesn't post before 3:00 a.m. Pacific
time which is the day because YouTube
switches over at midnight which is 3
a.m. Eastern I kind of when I was over
there was nice because I was you know
way ahead but it was that was a pain in
the ass and then when you go we go
anytime we tour like we go to Malaysia
we go to Japan we go Australia and stuff
like that you find out where who has
really crappy internet like how long it
takes right but it's all it's you've
always found a way to there's always
been away somehow if you find a way
determination you'll find it but the nd
you know you're wearing the Hat I KTV
right now that you know coining the
phrase the internet killed television
right is you you coined that very early
on I've had that for I don't know how
for the daily vlogs I wait before I was
like listening to the Buggles Internet I
mean Radio kill the internet star radio
the TV star that can't remember anymore
what's TV and I saw I listened to that
and I was like I wonder if this domain
is open you know I just bought it
immediately because I was like it's
available right I was bought for like 20
years or whatever it is yeah and it was
just I don't know it's I just noticed I
was not watching TV anymore I was
watching all my friends on the internet
watching you guys over watching Lisa I
was watching Shay is watching everybody
on the internet yeah again I mean it's
it's actually finally happening yeah you
know it's dead yeah I mean or almost did
almost dead yeah it's it's puttering out
its
gasps gasping for air it's buying the
internet right now that's what it's
doing the Internet is TVs now just
buying everything to be on the internet
yeah it's just becoming yeah moldy it's
becoming television but there was a
point when there was a question if you
would get to see your prediction happen
this whole brain tumor thing all right
so there's a you know I want to go
through this because there's a couple of
layers here
there's just the fact that you had a
brain tumor and we went through it right
yeah and then there's a layer of and you
document your life every single day and
they're not going to stop yeah because
if you could let just just between us
and everybody's listening if you could
ever come up with an adequate excuse to
start stopping I think a brain tumor is
on the list yeah I thought so too but no
but it's funny because if you actually
had stopped at the very beginning and
like made an informed decision before
these before you embarked on the daily
content like whatever if yeah it's like
well if I'm gonna do this every day what
if something really bad happens to me
you know I mean do you recall thinking
about that or was it just Shay's doing
it he did it for four weeks now I'm
gonna do it and yeah I just said I was
gonna do it's now doing it was it was
just one of those things I was like I'm
just gonna do it it wasn't like what is
no I've never your kid you know I was
like 20 20 years old or something like
that when I was doing all this stuff
like a pug ass kid you know stupid hair
I wasn't really caring it's just didn't
think about they could foreseeable
things like that you don't think about
stuff like we were a kid you just think
about what you're doing you know what I
mean it was in and so there was an
announcement to your audience I have a
brain tumor but right I mean there was
some there was some part of your life
that made it into the daily vlog that
gave Inklings - hey something might be
up right right she had a seizure first
right I had a seizure on tour yeah okay
yeah I thought about that and I was on
seizure with we're walking in Boise
Idaho just before before the show we're
trying to see that blue field because
that's all I think is that Boise so we
were walking we
daniyar drummer and then he said I just
kind of did like a spin and just hit the
face first
I had like a I iced coffee Starbucks
iced coffee Starbucks if you want to
sponsor me I've been drinking you
forever
but you gave him a brain to save my face
so I landed face first on the ice coffee
okay saved by Starbucks yeah so instead
of the cement I literally had a little
gash and a hole of my jeans which became
very fashionable but um yeah so just
that happened I went to the hospital
just hanging around Danny
we were playing like games on our phone
at the same time he broke his arm like
two weeks prior so the band was best and
uh I mean a drummer with one paw killed
it though he killed it yeah he killed it
the I Def Leppard just needed it yeah
you just kill we had our drummer drum
tech Yoshi like that parts would just
hit the cymbals it was really funny
actually so you were making it work but
then you've got to go in you're like
well okay now it's my turn yeah I had to
go check out yeah you know let's go you
know like you know I fell down they took
me to the the hospital Dr or whatever
and I'm just sitting there the guy comes
in you know face is kind of like white
and he's like I got something to tell
you and by immediate reaction on
anything is humor so I don't I knew
something was wrong with my head so I'm
just like he's like I got something to
tell you I'm like it's not a brain tumor
it's not a tumor or whatever immediately
go to Arnold Schwarzenegger right huh
and he's like no sir
it is oh this is a too much impression
back to you know it if I would have made
things much better but obviously I went
what first you don't understand it and
then because you don't understand
something like that that's something I
don't think very few people like
understand and that's why I continue
doing these videos is because there's a
lot of people out there to watch these
videos that are going through that or
have family members and so it went
through all that you know had to go I
mean that has to hit you like a ton of
bricks like it does at that moment
you're just but you're still young you
don't really get it you think you're
invincible you don't have mean you're
like yeah well whatever you know it's a
tumor get it out so you didn't think I
was something to die known at one point
I didn't think I was gonna die I just
thought like you know whatever take it
out my head and he was like alright so
because the doctor the
they assigned me to in Boise which was a
great Hospital camera were the name of
the hospital great Hospital club that
won him Boise Boise I know Shea would
know it um the guy was very confident
about everything and he was like yeah we
could take it out right away and I was
like okay do it right now and he's like
well you have to be here for say three
weeks and I'm like well I want to be in
Idaho for three weeks
so we flew home we found a doctor over
there and um got it out first one was
sleep I guess I was asleep um they
thought it was okay well how big are we
talking about if our own golf ball okay
there's a golf benign it was
well technically all tumors are they
have they're benign is like a weird word
they say okay cuz um it was technically
benign first time and then I guess it
turned into something without treatment
into more malignant okay and went
through the whole surgery and then I got
a I always have to give credit tally
speed she killed it with the editing I
couldn't do anything and she helps so
much with the editing on that because I
was like doped up you know like I
couldn't even do anything with my hands
so she edited that's why we didn't miss
a day and that one was not that
procedure was not filmed that that one
was not feeling offended but the whole
process though it's not just the
procedure it's how much you have to make
a decision how much of this are you
sharing online yeah online because I
would imagine there's a temptation to
say well I'll just share I'll share just
enough right but then well let's just
wait until this will just give an update
and say this is what was happening I'm
filling you in yeah it's not like
youtubers in their secret project right
exactly to go away for a while and then
they cast them coming back with Bigfoot
yeah so wait so what did you decide cuz
obviously didn't miss a day but it's not
it's not like every second of your day
no it's it's it was one of those things
where I just sat down I was like it was
more helpful to kind of talk to a camera
and not have somebody really you know
say anything it was just like let me
just vent and then later you know we
kind of the conversation look at the
comments and then I started noticing
people commenting saying they'd gone
through it as well so
like well I mean if they were going
through it you know it's cool we're
having that little connection so we can
help each other and it was crazy and
then got that surgery was two years
later I had another seizure I was like
seizure free for like two like two years
or year like a year and a half and
that's what causes us is like like
seizures if you guys ever have a seizure
please get a checked out not to scare
you but just get a check out and yes so
they noticed something happened when I
got back off work tour and so I went
back in and they said it was back and I
was like oh no there we go again and so
they had to go to a different doctor
and I wasn't on chemo or anything that
car probably helped you know keep things
regulated yeah but because it was in the
same place it just grew back in the same
place well yeah technically the type of
it was it's called an oligodendroglioma
it's a lot and don't Wikipedia it scares
if you do because there's that at the
time did not mean told me not to and I
listened to my doctor really yeah I did
not do it my parents did and I can see
the face like look on their face because
there's like ones were like you can live
their whole life or you can be dead in
two years so it was like one of those I
was like and I was super healthy that
was young so he's going through it all
and the doctor I mean he he was calling
you yeah you could a kid we could take
care of this you could be fine or you
could die in the next right well he
didn't obviously didn't say they didn't
know what it is until they take it out
your head oh yeah so we didn't know what
it was until after the surgery
unfortunately so then they found out and
that's the worst part is like you're
waiting for resolved by ops and you're
just like you think that would go a
little bit faster you know I mean they
pull something on your head it's like
what do I have and so you wait like two
or three weeks get the phone call he's
like alright well how are those two
three weeks then I mean sucks because I
mean you have to at some level you're
coming to grips with your mortality
right right yeah we're talking the
second time now oh this is the first
time I'm still the first time well still
yeah first time well the thing is like
that's what I think the vlogs really
helped is because you kept your mind
keeps your mind off of things
because otherwise you just sing at the
house you know watching TV you know
watching a movie you're just like in
back here
you know you're thinking about
everything versus working working yeah
cause it becomes a job by then it was a
job in every video it's not like you
mentioned it how much did you process
over those weeks of waiting like I you
know I thought it's fine I was like it's
what's okay you know whatever I'm young
I can take care of it I honestly didn't
think about it much at all
I I guess what I'm what I'm asking is
did you ever find your you're vlogging
to be a form of therapy for you you know
to find yourself processing things that
otherwise you wouldn't have talked to
Ali about or your parents about or your
friends about you find yourself
verbalizing things that yeah I think so
yeah cuz or did you just edit the action
points and your dogs into your videos
and it was just an escape it was kind of
both more of an escape probably if you
think about it cuz you you don't want to
dwell on things so it was kind of cool
like every single day I was able to just
focus on everyday having fun and then
just edit the video enjoy you know let
other people's and you know watching the
videos enjoy the video and if they're
going through the same thing they can
see that it's not a death sentence I
guess you could say and then so I just
kept doing that and then two years later
had another seizure like I was saying
and then got another doctor's opinion
said it was back this doctor said it was
a little more serious it was bigger and
so they showed me I don't have the
x-rays on here and we're on radio so we
can't really how big it was
this one was smaller Leo baseball Wow
so I got bigger so which was scarier
because you know they come back these
ones come back without treatment and
your skull doesn't get bigger just all
design just get smushed you get brain
get smushed I literally have like a like
a hole in your head and it's like fluid
it's very interesting and the x-rays are
really interesting though they kind of
see especially before and after before
it's just look like your brain it's like
a white brain boy brain like it's like
just white stuff you know praying like
filler and then when they take it out
it's this black gap and then you what
it's like fluid and things like that and
your brain doesn't it rain can't grow
and there your brains already grown so
you can't like isn't it like when you're
like a certain age your brains fully
grown
so as the as the cancer grew into that
baseball it just pushed it over yeah it
was more it was a tumor though I think
cancer and tumors I don't have the same
thing but like this at the tumor grew
yeah it pushes your brain over which
causes things like seizures and other
things like that some people smell
things like they'd be like who's cooking
steak or did you experience any nothing
else other weird stuff nothing else
sometimes like they can't see color it's
weird like it's a kind of like mine is
on the right side so it's frontal right
frontal lobe so it's supposed to be like
your motor skills on your left side
which sucks as a musician so you lose
everything right or when they take it
out you could be the best musician ever
so that's why I was hoping for but you
didn't experience any real physical
changes just a seizure just a seizure
and that's what everything else was fine
and then they did this surgery the guy
said he needed to get this one was the
surgeon two surgeons the rock star
surgeons he was like he would tell me
stories or how like him and the other
guy there were best friends we're in
like punk bands in med school in Boston
and they would go below the hospital and
like there's an abandoned part in the
hospital turned into a punk venue this
is my brain surgeon he's telling me all
that he was the rock star I just thought
you made it brain sir he is literally a
rock star it was just awesome Hallion
sometime guy he's one I actually brought
all the news from Kirk oh when Kurt
Cobain had his OD in a tout Italia Italy
and no one to give them the information
to America he was on the phone with
Courtney Love and Kurt getting all that
information back over here it was him
because he's Italian so he's the rock
star and so he's telling me all this
stuff he's like so we're gonna do you're
gonna be awake at first off I'm like
you're awake yeah and they was telling
me like you don't feel anything
you don't put your brains like heads
open you poke your brain yeah you know
yeah you probably lose like you probably
dumb but not hurt to get dumb you
wouldn't hurt to be Don you wouldn't
know you're getting done I guess but um
and you and so that's the first thought
is oh I'm awake second thought can i
film it yeah it was there was actually I
was like that was actually I don't know
why but I know my
my dad Willie are you thinking right why
is that the first thought and stuff like
that we like ask the doctor immediately
ask the doctor I was like he said sure
he said that sounds cool man he actually
loved it he loved the idea and he's like
sure he's like what kind of camera is it
he's like cannibal crew obviously and
I'm like I was like I have this little
camera right here and he's like yeah no
problem so I bring it in I have the I
guess there was two surgeons there was
main surgeon and there was another
surgeon and the other surgeon was like
trying to figure out how to do it and so
I literally had I don't know if the
clips actually made it in because Ali's
speed actually edited for me because I
couldn't do it obviously um couldn't do
anything um so that makes sense
uh and the other reason why I couldn't
do is because right after the surgery
the game in the nurse ad I don't want
she did this she gave me the camera
like right after the surgery and the
first thing you do after filming
anything you're like looking through
things and you're like oh you know what
the hell what is this you see her brain
and then I had what's called a what's
just called a stress attack or something
like that yeah and you were watching the
footage back you know brain brain being
hacked down right like 20 minutes prior
so I had this effect and like the camp
the guy another surgeon I mean that
nurse came in and grabbed my camera
actually what you doing you know they
had this argument and so she did all the
editing for that so I didn't see it for
a long time literally I haven't seen
that but you were telling them how to
use the how to use the camera to film
the thing I told him how to and then he
saw me how I was doing it because I was
like filming it and my arms went down
and they're like okay so we got to do
this so the surgery trying to hold the
camera I was trying to hold it my left
hand and that's the arm that actually
was affected by the tumor okay so I was
actually filming at first maybe I want
to think it looks like ten minutes but
it was probably 30 seconds I mean there
aren't tripods that is that what I
wanted the more like you want to had the
vlog thing yeah a tripod it just looks
like a surgeon video but right he's like
rating for my face he's like so what are
you thinking right now I'm like talking
about you know this is one of the nurses
the surgeon another surgeon oh really
there's there's a camera so they were
comfortable like adding a layer of
documentation that they became the
document in their own process right they
could
like seriously malpractice suit they
could have screw themselves over no it's
crazy that they allowed it yeah like did
they allow to happen they started a drop
the camera as brain yeah any questions
and like you you're talking about the
surgeons and how great they were you
were talking about fans and how great
their support was you were vlogging I
was talking I was telling apparently
they said I had my humor totally was
intact I was like like you were groggy
I watched it yeah it really was in there
I watched it maybe a year ago it was
first I've ever watched it because
there's two versions there's the
censored version and cachet Carla
actually came out to when the surgery
happened and art singer actually came
out as like most moral support Jay and
Kassim came out the first time for the
second one Shea's there and he's with
Ali went they were editing and she's
like I don't know I should put in shades
like put all of it no it's like she
always does and so we made two of them
because there it was pretty graphic you
see blood but it's not like gushing
blood like you know but you see some
brain so you see a brain it doesn't look
it looks like if you yellow put like
pink jelly so hard on yourself right
giant brain a giant giant brain but it's
interesting because I watched the
uncensored version recently and it's
it's interesting that they can do that
kind of stuff yeah so it was cool that
they did that but then I mean on an
emotional level I think the thing that
when I was watching through it it was
which one did you watch the uncensored
or the regular one well I'm actually
talking about kind of this the whole
story the story around it and how I mean
it was so compelling because it's so
real and it's so just a part of
something that you had committed it
broke you committed to something groped
blindly and then when this happens you
stuck with it yeah
and as Rhett and I watched it I remember
our conversation I was very curious
about the emotional side up right you
know I think that it was I was very
curious how you were dealing with it and
then how much of that would be conveyed
to the audience right I think a
connection really formed on that one
because like it was cool because you're
connecting with people maybe 10% of
people have something like that or
relate to that so I was able to vent to
somebody that knew is like going to a
support group because they told me I
should go to support groups because it
messes with your have to be joking but
your brain yeah but your mental state
and I refused to do any of those just
because you said earlier I'm a stubborn
person and I didn't want to do that I
wanted to go on tour I wanted to go play
shows and here's a funny thing right
after that surgery after both surgery
after the first surgery I was back on
the stage touring overseas in Europe in
two weeks
Wow yeah and I still had the freaking
you know what's uh that actor in a fifth
element that has the hair you know like
it's over the bad guy yeah yeah this is
Gary Sinise I carry Sinise is it it's
Gary Oldman Gary Oldman yeah you know in
the fifth element that's why I look like
that
- little collar and stuff like that
overseas so I would wear a helmet and
over like two weeks overseas second one
when I was open brain surgeries back on
the stage in three weeks because they
told me they're like you can do it do it
and I was like yes I mean you had this
like big it big circle of horseshoe
horseshoe yeah just right there over
your right eye yeah scout yeah the
Indianapolis Colts actually sent me a
care package
that's here thanks for getting our logo
yeah that's a side down though yeah yeah
they totally did it was really funny
it's amazing yeah I was really hilarious
too but yeah it was pretty gnarly kind
of situation I thought it was more of
like oh that was my moral support the
internet and I feel like things came
together really well in that how low did
it get though I mean there had to have
been moments where it was like if you
said I never felt like I was gonna die
even the second time I mean what there's
got to be those questions of Prosecco
process don't eat your mind I don't I
don't think when you're going through
that stuff it's just least me I don't
think death that I would think of it as
a situation kind of thing like I'm not
gonna die but I'm going through
something pretty but I know there's
somebody else going through
like there's somebody probably going
through stage for leukemia or breast
cancer or something like that and
they're going through really bad
chemotherapy they're losing their hair
you know they can't speak they can't
move I know there's unfortunately people
going through those things so when I
able to talk and I'm talking people back
and forth and I realize this situation
sucks but it's life you got to go
through it okay well let me see if I can
get at it this way because what I'm
still trying to find in there is that
moment of fear okay
the fear I'm trying to find the fear so
this is my last-ditch effort to find it
the drugs help I think I think it's did
you make any plans for like situations
yeah what would the video be like what
how do your funeral I actually did give
my password to Ali and I've said make
sure to film and keep going with this
thing I did tell her to keep going if
you did but if I died I didn't say it I
said if something happens please keep
this going
that's all I said meaning the channel or
the camera the channel but the camera -
I guess what like though they're gonna
go in there cuz I remember in the video
you can hear they're like Charles
Charles can hear us Charles and use here
my arm fall and I'm not able to respond
and then you hear clink clink clinking
that we're done and so they stopped so
they stopped filming but I was mainly
for her I wanted the channel to keep
going because I don't want to build
something and then make this community
and then just die
because unfortunately if I passed away I
felt like it needs to live on because
yeah it was bigger than me at the time
so you didn't think about an epic drone
swooping shot across your funeral that
would probably that happen to DGI mine
but then it would keep going after that
yeah I wanted to keep going yeah but I'm
never could thought about that part
thanks link one I give you my password
to do one and we're all gonna die and
there should be a drone at all of our
funerals ah just like DJ I'd like
phantoms drones all over the place yes
exactly right
open casket right yeah really slow rider
for this somebody's gonna do that
okay now you've you've mentioned
Alex peed a number of times he was with
you in the in the middle of all this and
of course your because your life has
been out there for everyone to see
everything's we've all feel like we know
a whole lot about your relationships
right experience and so we're going to
talk about that okay so let's talk about
the Ali's what I can say so there's
there's three you've actually met all
three all of them yes sort of like one
of the very first times we met after the
the cheese the cheese bread yeah right
incident YouTube live right yes yeah we
met Ali who you had you you know you are
already kind of putting your life on the
Internet at the time not in the same way
but like the the famous hot air balloon
proposals of yeah which I don't believe
can be found anymore
I think as we're taking that because it
was owned by a different company okay
yeah I don't buy a company but that was
sort of like the beginning of life I'm
gonna put myself out there and you're
gonna know about what I'm what I'm going
through
yeah and of course you know kind of
looking back on it we just want to hear
it from your perspective right because I
mean I think that there's I mean there's
obviously the thing that people always
talk about and joke about it's just like
does she have to be named out anywhere
for you to be with her doesn't John have
a book about that too like a life full
of out of it like was a bunch of Ali's a
boy - of Katherine Katherine said they
made the book abundance of alleys you
know I was like okay that's all right no
I mean like honestly it just it just
happens it happened like that
so what was it not a policy that's a
pulse I only bet was there when when you
met your current girlfriend Allie with
Allie Wes when you met her and you found
out her name was Ali was there a oh man
this might be a deal breaker or yourself
something else no I was gonna that
wasn't a deal breaker this war of like
oh this is going to be weird now it
wasn't gonna be weird for me because I
names a name you know I don't really
care some people date several John's in
their life you know what I mean right
just because it's on the internet I
think it makes a weird and it's
practical back and it's back to back
back yeah it's interesting but I think
that but you know so i yeah you know the
bigger question I think that
that everybody has is just the whole
process of what happened between you and
Ally speeding and leading up to you and
Ally West right and can we at least tie
a bow on the fact that you had a
proposal to Ally number one and Ally
with a y-yeah leads to Ally our ally
alright okay
you guys never got married no no right
yeah okay her family wasn't very
supportive the YouTube thing so it's
kind of like one of those things that's
like you know you do things that you
love the family is not supportive it's
like you know deal-breaker yeah
so now I wish I can go there just like
middle finger you know do the whole like
Homer Simpson going down the sand pit
you know like in the movie just brick
but I mean it's just one of those things
it's like you know you gotta have you
know these family supporting what you're
doing even though it sounds crazy you
know and that didn't happen that because
you know she didn't like it she didn't
support it family didn't support it so
immediately off the table so Alex peed
that was you guys got married in
November 2011 and there was you know
there's you guys she was on the channel
and there were the daily vlogs were
already happening so she was
incorporated into that the engagement
like the actual moment of engagement
right was part of that right and not I
know no not everyone but that one was
that what took I got a fear of flights
hot everyone's after that one yeah no I
mean like she's she's a wonderful woman
I never want to talk bad about her she's
a wonderful woman a very strong woman
and she's helping through a lot of
things and she it just so happened that
it's just you know worked out this way
but you know all that fun stuff
well yeah though it life the reason why
that's on there is obviously it's cuz
life happened from 2009 due to what is
2015 yeah and so life has happened for
seven years so that's why that's on
there and you can documented itself well
you know I think you know coming from
the perspective of you know we see you
on the internet a lot more than we see
you in person so that's an unfortunate
thing is right you so it's like we kind
of we see your life being lived as your
fans see your life being lived right so
when I mean I remember the the
announcement video the
I think you called it we need to talk or
write you know letting everybody know
that you guys were getting separated and
you know to quote something from that
video over the past couple of months Ali
and I haven't have just haven't been
getting along we have been arguing a lot
more than normal and it's just been
getting worse and worse and we've just
been becoming more and more unhappy and
stressed out right and of course you
know as two guys who you know we've been
married for a while right
and we I course the fans kind of
responded in the same way we heard that
and I was like there's got to be
something beyond this because what you
described is something that happens in
every marriage relationship right and
just as a fan watching your videos we
nobody had any idea that there was
anything that was wrong right and the
thing is that with the I remember a long
time ago we decided when the video
started that I didn't want a feathers
too much negativity that I didn't want
to do negativity on that it wants to
Jersey Shore if you want to watch that I
mean I wanted to show positive because
the ID drama drama yeah it clicked yeah
okay the videos may have been a bit like
a reality show I mean it's like a
homemade reality show but we have the
control over it so it was like one of
those things it's like a time capsule
almost a little bit better I guess to
say and the idea was when I get older
that whole idea of these videos when I
get older and I show my kids I want to
make sure they know I was cool at one
point so I wanted the show like you know
cool little things that I've done in my
life and remember cool little things cuz
I have a terrible memory prior to the
tumor and uh maybe that's all connected
I don't know
but um I wanted to have something that
can look back on and kind of reminisce
and see all these cool things I do
because I mean you guys probably know
they all the cool you guys do you
probably don't remember half of it Yeah
right
oh yeah and it certainly resonates with
me when you say this is the show I was
in charge of it was also my life and it
was I hear you saying it was you know
you and Allie it was your life together
for that stand of time right and you
made the decision to not exploit that
for the sake of entertainment value I
mean you could have done that like you
said that would have been entertaining
what reality TV like that is just
slapping someone in the head right
exactly and yeah that was a very
difficult video issue
thinking back on it I wish she was a
part of it but to be honest with you it
was a very difficult thing just to shoot
by myself and a very difficult whole
thing was a difficult situation its it
seemed like it was almost like I'm just
gonna do this
almost like was the spur of the moment
it certainly didn't seem like a there
was a plant again I think was literally
shot on my webcam yeah there was no it
wasn't like a prepared statement by any
means no I rambled forever I don't know
what to say like cuz he's you go with
what you're thinking and stuff like that
but it wasn't satisfying as a viewer ya
know some people they want more you know
everyone wants more especially and I
respect that you know people are
invested in watching these things for
sometimes like some people I met today
seven years you know since day one and I
understand I respect that but at the
same time it's hard to you know it's
like mom and dad divorcing or something
like that you know think why was it us
you know I mean so it's kind of hard to
explain that and it was a very difficult
situation for both her and of myself and
we didn't know what we were getting we
didn't know how to deal with ourselves
so to explain that to a million and a
half people you know how do you do that
and I just one day what I was like in
the day I was just like I had something
in my head and I just turned on the
webcam literally used iMovie and just
started talking right and you know just
said what I and had had you guys
discussed I mean obviously you had made
the decision that you were getting
separated but had you discussed the
process by which you would let everyone
know oh we did and like I said like I
thinking back I wish we both were on
there to explain it what a bit better to
say everyone down like so to speak but
for me I was just one of those
spur-of-the-moment things like you said
I just had something on my mind I wanted
to say and I when I watched it again I
was like this seems kind of genuine so
versus me kind of like going back and
hey guys you know I love all turning on
the real camera and stuff like that I
wanted to be more genuine speaking for
my heart and you know things happened
you know and there's definitely things I
wish I would have done differently
obviously everybody wishes they do you
think retrospect captain hindsight but
um very difficult time obviously yeah
and I do apologize to everybody who's
you know effect
by that you know her her family people
watching the videos my family everybody
is it I mean it is the decision that
you've made that okay we've moved on
obviously each of you yeah and so
there's no need I don't want to ask the
question I just want to ask you about
the principle of not shedding any more
light on it like Rudd even though that
was kind of a spur-of-the-moment thing
that was kind of the at least that's the
last thing I've said that you've really
kind of gone on record about it right
well I mean I've done stupid things
everyone does stupid things when you're
angry and stuff like that and I that's
what I'm saying like I definitely wish I
could take back but you say things when
you're angry and stuff like that but I
see what he's saying like I kind of it's
happened a long time ago she's happy I'm
happy I'm so happy for her and I just
want everyone else to you know move on
yet it was a situation and I do
apologize you know things suck you know
I mean but it's life and that's the
whole point of these videos it's kind of
what I'm saying is like that's the whole
point of these things is like you know
went through a brain tumor filmed it
went through a divorce filmed it this is
life everyone's telling your parents
might go through the same situation
things like that happened and kind of
the point of what I was doing with the
videos I didn't want to stop didn't want
to like hide it or anything like that
can't sugarcoat that you can't put a
like a CGI person or something like that
a replace or anything like that you have
to explain things but there was I mean
leading up to the separation there was a
lot of editing that had to be made right
there were people I think people went
back and they wanted to find out where
they could see the signs like oh I know
I can see it they weren't together yeah
or when they were together it was like
this right yeah there's because it's
like a treasure hunt for some people and
and they want you know when the
attachment goes so deep as seen a couple
go through brain surgery and you know
it's how did you impact how did you
experience a backlash cuz I have to
think that people were upset I went
through this brain surgery with you man
and then you're gonna you know no of
course of course and like you know they
want I imagine they've thrown you under
the bus they've thrown both of us under
the bus okay which sucks I mean in any
relationship they're gonna throw because
if people feel betrayed and I respect
that fact you know because people are
invested in you for someone so long and
then it's just over but it's not so much
over like I said in the video it's just
the next chapter you know what it lets
what happens in life is like there's
relationships and breaks ups breakups
all the time in life and I feel like
everyone's gone through a breakup in
life maybe some of the younger ones are
going to so it's going to suck but it
happens and you go on to the next
chapter and you make yourself happy and
you want happiness for the other person
and you just move on life right yeah and
you know you express in that video that
you you wanted to remain close to tally
speed exactly what what's this what's
the relationship like now well we we
were very cordial we aren't very close
obviously you know there's still some
you know there's still you know some
things you know we're still working on
because it was it's a hard thing to go
through you know emotionally so you know
it takes time to heal I'll be both for
the internet and both for us you know I
mean I know the Internet's still healing
over that and we're actually still
healing over that so I know a lot of
people are like wanting that quicker and
it's like you know we put all these
videos on the internet and I know people
want to see things quicker but we're
still healing
you know lifesteal handling soon so but
you come to something like VidCon you
guys you cross paths that's the
difficult thing oh that's what I'm
saying like we're very cordial when you
see each other yeah we see the phils
wedding and things like that very
cordial I mean we're not don't hate each
other but it still takes time to heal
wounds and I'm happy she's moving on
she's getting her life together well I'm
being happy as well so and I have a
wonderful girlfriend as well so you know
moving on with our next chapter in life
and was there I mean that whole process
of like okay I've announced this
separation and now I've got this new
woman in my life how did you make
decisions about when you were going to
introduce right I say where's that alley
yeah to your audience because there's I
mean you know obviously there's the
internet is just completely
full of speculation about the timeline
and but I'm not gonna speculate about
that right internet enough speculation
of people think things and it got to
love reddit for digging deeper but yeah
I mean people find timelines but it's
not what it appears on the Internet just
because it's on the internet doesn't
mean that's what it was and that
unfortunately people have made wrong
assumptions on all accounts on so many
things and you know we were wanting to
take her time to introduce you know we
were still taking our time so we didn't
want to rush into things as well you
know so we had to take our time before
we made the decision to I mean
essentially introducing somebody to
anybody even bringing anyone into a vlog
for me is like introducing to your
family yeah so it takes some time to
think about it and then eventually do it
but unfortunately things happened and we
were forced really quickly because
people were making wrong assumptions and
you know things got really out of hand
really fast on both for her and for
myself and you know can't have that I
didn't want that the hate that was going
to it was affecting too many people too
quickly and how did you how did she
handle that coming in I mean obviously
when you just look at it from an
outsider just watching your vlogs
it's like hold on they were this was a
happy family a couple of months ago
right yeah and now there's a new girl
and she's named Allie yeah what yeah and
then they they think just because of the
worst thing I would have to say is just
because things are on the internet
doesn't mean it's what they are because
like just because somebody likes a photo
likes comments or something like it
likes an Instagram photo they assume the
worst like if you like something for
example your wife isn't gonna think
something like you know what I mean
right
I like I don't I've liked food took
pictures of walls you know - anything on
Instagram is people take that and run
with assumptions and I feel like that's
where the internet kind of needs to just
trust people and just to clarify you're
addressing the allegations that there
was a relationship but before prior yeah
and which it was not and that was
completely wrong and out of control and
I felt bad because Allie Wes was being
brought into something like this and
she was taking it like a champ but deep
down she was hurt very hurt that people
were saying things and assuming things
based on nothing you know what I mean -
assuming assumptions and she's taken
some time it's been a year and a half
everyone's moving on it's great because
you know life is moving on and stuff
like that she's able to come to these
VidCon things she's meeting people
people are you know kind of apologizing
to her mainly for making the assumption
that you know not giving her a chance
and stuff like that and saying horrible
things and it's I understand she
understands - so you know she talks to
him that you know people get hurt you
know they say things really quickly
without thinking and it's nice to see
that the Internet's coming back together
because there was a rough there was a
rough year and a half yeah well I know
you guys have moved on but we appreciate
you taking the time to to talk about it
of course you talk about everything yeah
I know I'll definitely definitely it's
actually the first time I actually got
to really talk yeah online about it so
it's pretty was kind of nervous nervous
about that but hopefully under everyone
understands it and doesn't take things
the wrong way but yeah well thanks for
you know being open oh yeah and what now
I mean is there an end date to the vlogs
are you going if are you gonna do it
what's today the 27th something
something we don't know yeah I'm 27 the
20th
you'll never know guys as long as you
keep doing it it's a record that no one
can ever break that's the interesting
thing yeah it's not like setting a world
record in like the breaststroke yeah you
know you have to wait at least seven
years for somebody or break it yeah
right so I'll have seven years of being
nervous yes so I don't know I really
honestly don't know I so many cool
things that I could probably have in my
life you know the band's tour still
touring a lot you know yeah we didn't
get a chance to talk about that yeah and
now you're a rock star in addition to
all these other that was a great thing
that I kind of stumbled into because
we've been friends with as a kid you
know recording that filming that you
know the process of that doing the
albums and just life you know you know
eventually I'm saying this down the line
guys don't get assumptions you know kids
you know down the road
family and it's really exciting to see
down the world road to be able to
document that - yeah that's a huge
process I mean you guys have kids so you
know there's yeah but I guess if Shay is
any example eventually you just won't be
able to keep up anymore it's gonna yeah
you're gonna start dropping days watch
those kids go yeah
day 18 off the stopcock
maybe stopping kid 18 I'm sorry all
right man well uh we don't want you to
stop so keep going and we wish you the
best
hey thanks for uh of course for letting
us process all this with you of course
thank you guys for having out here
here's a fun little game guys go back
and listen to this and see how many
times I voice correct okay all right and
are we gonna fly we're gonna put a vlog
you've logged before we started yeah I'm
gonna vlog know that you survived it
okay guys so we're just now ending what
episode number is this whoa now you're
getting really technical I mean eighty
something okay eighty something of ear
biscuits and I just wanted to say I'm
vlogging on it so I'm vlogging on it
right now
did you do you feel good I feel because
you were like I don't know how this is
gonna be you didn't know I didn't know
what it was gonna be like I actually
really actually this is what I sound
like this is actually kind of
interesting but ya know we actually
talked about a lot of things I was
really super nervous
luckily these guys are people I probably
know I'm probably the most ten years
right yeah getting here getting close a
decade yeah getting old so yeah you guys
can listen to this whenever they upload
it when you guys upload let's see we're
batching these so it'll be a few weeks
we're gonna make it we're gonna make you
wait a little bit right probably the
most nerve-wracking thing I've ever
talked about and you got it out of me
all right
[Music]
and there you have it our conversation
with Charles Trippy tweeted him guys let
him know what you thought about
conversation his handle is Charles
Trippy use hashtag ear biscuits yeah and
especially we want to just express that
we appreciate him being so open
he told us after we finished recording
that he was nervous about coming on here
knowing that we would ask some questions
about his relationship with ally and and
you know he's lived his life in front of
everyone out there who watches his
content but you know that's he can cut
edit it right I mean it's his life and
he's extremely open about it but he has
the ability to kind of present it in a
way that he's like well if I don't want
them to know about that then I won't
tell him but he had the courage to come
on here and let us basically grill him
towards the end there okay about these
these questions and the internet
speculation so and address some of that
yeah thanks to Charles for doing we
appreciate that tweeted him let let him
know what you think you know another
thing that I really enjoyed about the
conversation was it was a refresher for
me going you know going back through his
experience all the way to the beginning
of YouTube with how much he did help
shape what so many people after him
started to do like I said in the intro
to developing a genre of clickable
Internet content even before the daily
vlog thing you know just having them he
was one of the only people that was
getting traction on those kind of videos
way back in the day and and pushing just
pushing the medium in a lot of ways not
the sketches and also just vlogs and
everything in between that just became
clickable thumbnailing tile every single
name any aspect of it and you could
always kind of look at his channel and
figured it out and I was reminded of
that one thing we didn't talk about
another example of experimentation was
the live stream where he and Sheikh Carl
and it's Brent you remember this all
three of them decided to see who could
stay up the longest and it's it
precipitated from the new technology of
live streaming and people doing life
casting like
justine was broadcasting every moment of
her day but even when she slept and a
couple of other people were doing that
on justin.tv I think they were on blogtv
when that started I can't remember I
think that's where it was not Ustream
not Justin but blog TV because we went
into the chat room we had met him in
Philly and then we were like becoming
more the community so we were able to
enter each person's chat room and I
don't know how long they stayed up I
don't one that didn't try Carl in it I
think Shane me of one but it was I mean
it was days that they stayed up and they
were broadcasting all of it on the
internet and you know at a certain point
they were all like falling asleep in
front of their webcams which is
hilarious with people in the comments
like talking to him maybe we should do
that again I don't want to be a part of
it though I hate staying up oh yeah
me too I mean it gets it past midnight
now I'm just like what what is this a
lock-in
but it's the spirit of experimentation
and pioneering captured in that moment
that it's just like okay you can live
stream let's do it without sleeping
it'll be fun you know he and Shay were
spurring each other on even with the
daily vlog thing and unit in it it's
just a lesson and a reminder that when
you try things things happen that you
didn't expect there's unexpected
byproducts that might lead to your
career or breaking a Guinness World
Record or doing seven years of you know
that continues to be the thing that is
just blows my mind and you know as
coming from two guys who yes we do have
a date a daily internet show but we're
not constantly broadcasting our lives
and we're and we don't have to
personally edit every single second of
video every single day and I'd really
cannot believe it there's no one's ever
gonna come close to the record I mean I
just did just no way it's gonna be
broken I mean first of all it continues
to build every single day right but
there's no way anybody else is gonna
break that well it's possible especially
if they invent technology to age twice
as fast would that count towards
catching up well you know the reason it
will never be broken in a way that he's
doing it
which is someone who's filming it and
then editing themselves but when it
becomes like a robot camera that's on
you that does a automatic that doesn't
count because that's gonna happen that's
next I think the bigger question is why
on earth would anyone develop technology
to age twice as fast oh I didn't even
know III heard you I thought you said I
assumed that you said age more slowly
big because that would have made some
sense I did listen you gotta age faster
you every your do every one of your days
has to equal everyone else's two days in
order for him to catch it or her to
catch up with Charles well in seven days
from now we'll have another ear biscuit
for you and Charles Trippy will have
seven more vlogs for you you know that's
sort of the that's the pattern that
we've all established and you can count
on all of us as we've established so
we'll speak at you next week guys thank
you
[Music]
[Music]